qu'on se le dise s'il n'est plus en
plateau pour présenter chaque jour son
journal de 13h sur tf1 jean pierre
pernaut n'a pas pour autant perdu son
franc parler d'ailleurs depuis la crise
du coronavirus le journaliste le plus
populaire de france s'est montré
particulièrement virulent face aux
décisions du gouvernement qu'il n'a pas
hésité plusieurs fois à critiquer
notamment sur le maintien du premier
tour des municipales ou encore sur le
manque de masse et ce vendredi jean
pierre pernaut a remis ça le journaliste
s'en est pris cette fois ci au décalage
de discours qui existe entre la forte
répression policière dont on parle dans
les reportages pour éviter que les gens
sortent de chez eux et la réalité dans
une ville à côté de chez moi
un monde fou sur les trottoirs des
adultes des enfants qui jouent plein de
monde sans masque sans contrôle quel
contraste avec les reportages où on nous
montre des pv infligé à des gens qui se
promènent tout seul sur une plage tout
ça paraît incohérent visiblement très
remonté le journaliste ne s'arrête pas
là car pour lui les gens ne sont pas les
uniques responsables de cette situation
le gouvernement et ses consignes
construisent sont la base du problème
comme les masques interdit dans les
pharmacies est autorisée chez les
buralistes dont vous parliez tout à
l'heure
comme les fleuristes fermait pour le
premier venait des jardineries ouverte
comme les cantines diatta ouverte mais
les restaurants toujours fermée avant
d'enchaîner toujours plus en colère
entre les infos un jour sur un
déconditionnement par région le
lendemain ses pulls par région un jour
l'école est obligatoire le lendemain
elle n'est plus un appartement pour
quinze jours de cours puisqu'il requiert
un enfant sur deux dans les classes dont
tout ça donne le tournis un coup de
gueule saluée par de nombreux
internautes mais aussi par des stars
comme jean marie bigard qui semble avoir
beaucoup aimé le coup de sang de jpp -
jean-pierre j'ai vu ton coup de gueule
sur tf1 c'est génial jean pierre tu es
un tueur un confinement qui semble taper
sur le système de tout le monde
et franchement je sais pas ce que vous
en pensez mais jean pierre pernaut ou
soit d'accord avec nous pas il a du
courage il est sur tf1 en direct le mec
il y va franchement long terme vous avez
vu un autre journaliste faire ça est-ce
que franchement après on est d'accord
avec lui ou pas mine de rien c'est quand
même incroyable ce qu'il a fait sur tf1
gilles verdez indépendance d'esprit
totale il peut aussi parce qu'il n'est
pas présente en faire en tant que tel
donc il a un rôle de chroniqueur mais il
ya en toute liberté et surtout il ne
laisse pas le ton mais il dit tout ce
que les français pensent ils pointent
toutes les contradictions
franchement j'ai également en douceur
remarquable on vous a posé la question
est ce que vous comprenez le coup de
gueule de jean pierson on va voir le
résultat dans un instant qui comprend le
coup de gueule raymond tu comprends pas
moi je suis entièrement d'accord avec
lui je comprends très bien son coup de
gueule il est libre il n'a plus rien à
prouver à personne sa carrière à l'excès
il en liberté totale c'est parce qu'il a
dit ce qu'elle risque et ce qu'il fait
c'est ce qu'a risqués ce qui fait moi je
tombais ans très bien et j'approuve ce
qu'ils disent les français sont pas
bêtes de la mare toutes les deux minutes
que les mecs nous disent tous les jouets
alors prouver le contraire en demande
beaucoup on demande juste qui est
démasqué du gène dont on sait qu'il va
falloir retourner que moi s'est pas
arrêté de nous mentir vraiment juste
restons sur jean pierre pernaut on va
voir le coup de gueule je comprends en
intégralité regardé et je crois qu'il y
en a deux qui sont pas tout à fait
d'accord c'est valérie
et le forcené regarde tous 39e jour 13h
à la maison en vivant finalement la même
chose qu'une grande majorité de français
avec un événement pour moi hier je vous
raconte tout ma première sortie sur
terre depuis six semaines pour un rendez
vous important et la surprise dans une
ville à côté de chez moi
un monde fou sur les trottoirs des
adultes des enfants qui jouent plein de
monde sans masque sans contrôle quel
contraste avec les reportages où on nous
montre des pv infligé à des gens qui se
promènent tout seul sur une plage ou en
montagne ou en forêt alors qu'il ya
aucun risque dans les régions n'y a pas
de virus tout ça paraît incohérent
incohérent comme les masques interdit
dans les pharmacies est autorisée chez
les buralistes dont vous parliez tout à
l'heure
comme les fleuristes fermait pour le 1er
mai mais des jardineries ouverte comme
les cantines bientôt ouverte mais les
restaurants bientôt toujours fermés on a
du mal à comprendre tout ça est
maintenant entre les infos un jour sur
un déconditionnement par région le
lendemain c'est plus par région un jour
l'école est obligatoire lendemain elle
n'est plus un appartement pour quinze
jours de cours puisque rock'n enfant sur
deux dans les classes donc tout ça donne
le tournis ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'aujourd'hui
après ce petit coup de gueule le
confirme en continu témoignage à
montigny sur loin près de fontainebleau
ce matin voilà donc avec jean-pierre
alors est-ce que ça dérange elle
d'accord avec le coup de gueule voilà
déjà ces courageux quoi qu'il arrive
prends jean michel maire jean louis où
je trouve ces très belles épaules de
présentateurs de jt potiche et les
révolue plus longtemps si les gens
regardent le jt de tf1 c'est parce
qu'ils ont une complicité intellectuelle
et jean pierre pernaut ci ne sait pas
que les images des images les voix un
peu parti un peu partout les mêmes
mais là ils se sentent en osmose avec
jean clair le panneau ils ont appelé les
mêmes idées que lui et agathe pour
autant qu'ils en oublient de dire parce
qu'ils pensent à peu la même chose donc
je sais très bien que la maison sophie
après normal comme valérie bénaïm et le
forcené qui ne sont pas d'accord
sophie non mais pour moi il a totalement
raison et jean pierre pernaut c'est une
star donc effectivement il fait ce qu'il
veut pour moi c'est un peul depardieu du
trésor probablement celle évolué dit
ascendant balance probablement un peu
plus tard merci alors que le forcené
pourquoi tu énergie non je suis pas
énervé mais voilà moi moi je suis je
suis comme ça je pense qu'on comprend
présente un journal
présente une info il doit la présenter
sans donner son avis même si excusez moi
quand vous dites il promet il prend un
risque excusez moi c'est tout ce dont on
pense tout bas narrateur mais excusez
moi ya pas de rival et 0 ap les il n'y a
pas un autre journaliste qui a dit la
même chose
non mais je suis d'accord mais ben voilà
réécouter vous me posez la question je
vous réponds donc je vous dis la vérité
moi pour moisson son avis il le garde
pour lui sinon il fait des tribunes
il est éditorialiste l'idée qui fait les
présentateurs non non non il
présentation de l'année doit présenter
une info et de la livre et sa prise de
risque la prison que c'est moi qui dit
qu il enfonce des portes ouvertes est
disque de mon porte tout au tout il le
dit tout
voila voila expo n'est pas anodine mais
on va y arriver il le dit lui la raison
même valérie benjamin a raison ce qu'il
a fait là est le rôle d'un éditorialiste
normalement sans être tiède sans être
passe-plat normalement le jtc alors
c'était sait plus vraiment le cas mais
c'était la grand messe est là pour
donner l'information
on lui demande d'être effectivement
factuelle de dire ce qui va ce qui ne va
pas de dire des choses mais on ne
demande pas son point de vue c'est pas
c'est pas eu lieu le lieu d'un point de
vue c'est un débat c'est le serviteur
analystes qu'il a expliqué pour quelle
raison il est d'accord ou pas d'accord
avec l'action mais là ils étaient en
plateau jusque là il délivre
l'information donc il dit voilà alors
qu'ils disent
l'information a évolué on nous a dit
avant ceci maintenant cela mais que
derrière ils disent moi ça me donne le
tournis belle chimie entre guillemets
jan fischer
alors on va l'envoyer ainsi que certains
paquebots cool m
ce sont là les rires on va voir on va
voir ce qu'on pense et téléspectateurs
les chéris regard des sondages je
comprends jean pierre pernaut le coup de
gueule j'en perds plaindre à 93% je ne
comprends pas à 7%